what a terrific feature that was from Christine
Simpson in our pregame show on Lena fullart and
here's n with the chance and hmark able to CL the
pass hold jeam fan reik with him right now it's
neander battling with maoy it comes to Matthews
back to Morgan Riley Austin Matthews from an
ankle put it in front nice tied up as he tried
to find that rebound knocked away from the front
of the net and fori crawls to get it back out to
Center ice pass the Midway Mark of the first Here
Comes poster knock scores oh there's a score to
release David poster knock with his 14th of the
year and such deception on the release of that
shot it's hard to find a way that he was able to
get it through the skates and the sticker knut
just is so comfortable when the space is taken
away watch Morgan Riley he's got his stick there
might have got a piece of it but it's the quick
little release by past takes a quick look then
takes it from the outside inside and that one
goes up and over the blocker side as you can see
maybe a little bit deep by Joseph wal not sure
he was thinking poock would even shoot from that
far HCK on to the Stick of Matthews after timan
fann on it Beno into the corner neander looks
for Matthews a hot shot stopped by Omar a jam
Play thar's Down L bin now it's Marner away
to Riley over the line and dumping it deep
into the corner and for two as he comes up with
it toar stop rebound chance that looked like it
may have hit Taris who was around it goes for
nander got n on the move and so is Matthews
here's Matthews off the post or n would like to
have that one back would he I mean what a play
there by nander to buy himself a little time and
open up the onetime for nine the BR took it from
nander gives the shot right on rebound collected
by Pasto great passing scores Kevin shot Kirk this
time it's a highlight re pass from David poock
over the glass but now past knock at the end of
the shift you're watching and nobody picks up the
defenseman coming in from the side look at shaton
C point back pass knock a no look pass and how
about this in tight shaton curk goes up and over
that's his first goal in 32 it looked like he had
done that a lot more as good play there by tarus
he knew he was one against three couldn't ice the
puck but just put it to an area the opposite side
of the bench great pass for verzi and ver knocked
off B nice stopped at the line Mel fire it deep
Matthews first man to it watched by makoy off
makoy Tim in front rebound nice stop by Omar
leaps Come Close here's thenen dies and omark
got it again rebound scores Austin Matthews rck
two
well there's a break you're looking for as a
couple of great Saves by almart looking Skyward
time and again there's the shot the good tip in
tight but he gets the rebound but can't get it
past the scrawling pad good job of neander keeping
the puck alive good shot in the middle there one
save neander pokes it off hits the defenseman M
boy and there's Matthews on the doorstep stayed
away from the traffic HED that Puck and gets the
break as the puck pops loose and just like that
that's the second time the cave is blocked one the
anle andar nearly got caught out of the net Marner
at the line and that pass will pull the leaf back
out they got to tag up and break back in after it
and in behind the net and a chance here
walls Dr that off loose puckets jumed
away light back in behind the N big trip
Frederick there Ben try to Ward him off
comes back to the line for shaton that doesn't
get through and now the leaps of counter Doby's
loose here's the pass Doby in scor first
is a leap it's a game Tire early in the
third well you talk about a reaction and a weight
off the shoulders and then it comes out of a good
play in the defense and then and then how about
this little Quick Pass the backhander gets knocked
off the Stick of sh that actually helps do I think
allar FES is going to come further across the net
he kind of gets stuck in the middle as this one
gets knocked down do for hand back hand and up
and over when you've got that kind of speed and
the puck is rolling that's just a great play to
make tell me that doesn't mean something here's
Robertson curling inside the line Tim swinging
a Miss then off the boards back in up ahead for
geeki into the middle he goes drops it off shot
bluk pu scores rebound cash Trent Frederick has to
go a hit goal for Boston Joseph wall is upset with
himself there he just he thought he had it the way
he reacted he and you open up the cross team you
give up the line now you're and that opens up that
seam and look at I think wall pick is got in his
GL look at him look down he did so this is one
that that's a whip for him as Frederick gets a
piece of it as it goes to wall wall looks down and
can't believe that he didn't have it in his glove
his reaction there was okay the plays over Riley
can't get to the puck first and Frederick does
and because he thought tovar's stick was right
on the ice behind him there's DZ working in over
down it comes back to Mar across SC game fir 4.8
to go and Austin Matthews has his second of the
night Omar gets knocked down and you know
it's the last minute so the league looks at
this but there's The Bu in front I think
that's a good one lyol took a little bit
of tarus but then Matthews opens up watch
Matthews get out of the pile is trying to
get open so he knows the mar will find the
open man instead of staying by the pile he
jumps back that creates the shooting
Lane he gets it up and over the P of
and there's your reaction in the crowd the
officials Chris as you would expect here
move there you go Matthews now with
the 11 career goals against the
B neander tried to that back to the point nobody
was there in front for marar kicked Away by olar
now lead feed it's a breakway Pavo zaka stop
rebound and rall with two stops Mar over skates
a loose puck in front and now Morgan Riley up
ahead neander behind everybody for the win elar
with the Stop and now neander deliberately through
Center look out rows a tire Breakaway David poock
for the win well again rebounded from scores the
Boston ruins in over time gr Maran has the winner
tonight ason comes out look he's trying to
direct traffic here didn't see Maran now it
takes a second for marshan to get out but past
not credit him he stops on this play throws it
back off the arm and then it's Maran on the
door step able to grab that rebound neander
trying to turn back lost his footing caut goes
for the five hole on the back hand doesn't get
it and Maran WS it down with his BL and puts
it into the back of the net boy the way this
game started looked like it was going to be a
lowc scoring Affair but here we are at the end
with seven on the board so the lead stoage
a point with 6 seconds left in regulation